all right I don't know why I find this
next clip so damn funny but I was
laughing hysterically this morning
watching this there's this kooky
Republican Congressman James Comer James
Comer is obsessed with talking about how
they're going to go after Joe Biden
they're going to investigate this
they're going to get him they're going
to get Biden's family now you all know
that that's ridiculous but James Comer
appeared last night on the Hannity Fox
news program I guess the Hannity Fox
news program now is shot with a live
audience and despite there being no
evidence of crimes committed by the
Biden family Comer is claiming to be
super confident that they are closing in
the walls are closing in on the Biden
family so this is this is a silly
nonsensical thing but Hannity's crowd
starts cheering when he says it they
just cheer
do they not realize that the walls
aren't closing in on the Biden family I
don't know but there's a little detail
that I don't know why this is so funny
when the crowd starts cheering and this
is very visual so I'll describe it to
people who are listening when Comer says
this the crowd starts cheering the
camera pans to the live audience for
Hannity's show and you see two people I
don't know if they're a couple or if
they just happen to be sitting next to
each other
and they are clapping and chewing gum so
aggressively why are you chewing gum at
a live taping of a TV show like I don't
know why I find it so weird but I could
not stop laughing when I saw this this
morning check this out it's all
ridiculous the the walls are closing in
no they're not the crowd cheering what
you guys do you guys believe this but
the gum chewing is just too much for me
it all points back to Joe Biden and
we're going to continue
until we
get American people but I can say this
shot the walls are closing in on the
Biden family
we appreciate you being with us thank
you
[Applause]
they look like ruminants chewing their
cud what the guy on the screen left the
gum is sticking out of his mouth why why
is there so much gum chewing happening
during this show and of course the truth
is the walls are not closing in on Joe
Biden's family if they're closing in
they're closing in at what we might call
a glacial Pace well we might have the
neck we might have the next ice age or
Trump's health care plan before the
bidens actually end up indicted so
people very excited on the Hannity
program for something they're being told
is happening which simply is not
happening I'm not a betting man but
that's something I'm willing to bet on
now of course remember I'm for Law and
Order so I say
if there is evidence of criminality
against anyone whether it's a Democratic
president a Republican president a
speaker of the house a vice president if
there's evidence that someone committed
a crime
investigate it if you find that indeed
it looks like they did commit a crime
charge them
try them do I'm not saying don't do it
I'm just saying I don't believe that
there is going to be any evidence that
the Biden family committed any crimes
all right let's move on